welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Jason Crawford Jason is the
founder of roots of progress which is an
organization dedicated to studying a new
philosophy of progress for the 21st
century Jason welcome to the podcast uh
thanks great to be here thanks for
having me great could you quickly
summarize the history of progress on
Earth for us you know the most pithy
summary maybe comes from I think it's a
Luke uh mulehauser I hope I'm
pronouncing his name correctly he said
basically everything was terrible for a
very long time and then the Industrial
Revolution happened slightly you know
less pithy with a little more detail um
you know I think the you can sort of
divide human history
um high level into kind of three eras
um there was the you know tribal
hunter-gatherer era which lasted some
tens of thousands of years or hundreds
of thousands depending on how you count
and then there was the agricultural era
which uh you know lasted another ten
thousand years or so and then for the
last few hundred years uh we've been in
the industrial era and the number one
thing I think if you wanna if you want
to summarize it all down to just kind of
like one concept or pattern I think the
most important thing to understand about
progress is that it compounds and
therefore it accelerates
um so if you map any you know various
metrics of progress you might have like
GDP per capita or even just world GDP or
um you know any other sort of various
similar metrics um like population or
energy usage or whatever and you map it
on a semi-log plot you know where
exponential curves become straight lines
it's not even a straight line it bends
upwards so the curve of of human
progress is actually super exponential
that is it grows greater than any
exponential it is you know potentially
you could think of it like exponential
growth except that the exponent itself
is increasing over time as uh as
progress compounds on itself even the
pace of progress itself you know gets
gets faster even on a relative or
exponential basis is this the mainstream
view in economics regarding economic
growth uh yeah I would say if you asked
um you know growth economists
um you know Paul Romer or Chad Jones for
instance would be you know very familiar
with this pattern and would tell you I
mean I apart in part I'm getting it from
them so so you mentioned that that
growth is accelerating growth compounds
upon itself
um what about these modes of growth so
you mentioned the agricultural era
perhaps the industrial era does it make
sense to talk of an of another a mode of
growth after that perhaps the
computational error I think it makes
sense to to to wonder about or predict
or uh you know think about such thing in
the future I don't think we're there yet
or perhaps we're right now at the
transition point or in the transition
phase between those but I don't think
we've seen enough of it yet to be able
to say that we're you know we've that
were in it or that we've made the
transition or or to know what it looks
like yeah what do we know about economic
growth doing the hunter-gatherer era and
all the agricultural era there's versus
now for example I mean the farther so in
general with history and with economic
history the farther back you go the
Sketcher the data gets and that happens
very rapidly right so like you know if
you try to go back before the 20th
century you hit just like we don't have
even very good like economic records and
if you try to go back before that we
don't even have good you know if you go
back more than a few centuries we don't
even have good population records and if
you try to go back farther than that if
you don't go back more than 5 000 years
we don't even have written records of
any kind and now we're just into
archeology and the farther you go back
the more the artifacts themselves have
decayed so any of these things you know
you have to anytime somebody's talking
about data from the past you have to
take it with a grain of salt and
understand there's a lot of inference
and interpretation here however that
said you know there are papers that
attempt to present very rough estimates
of population and even GDP going back
in some cases like a million or two
million years you know so back to our
hominin ancestors
um who are who are not even homo sapiens
and again the high level pattern is sort
of that so you know so one pattern is
that like population growth which in a
sort of malthusian regime where uh you
know living per capita living standards
kind of never really increase population
growth and economic growth are more or
less the same thing the the high level
pattern of population growth is roughly
that population growth rates are
proportional to population itself
right so again the the the exponent
um on the on the exponential growth
increases with population itself right
where the absolute amount of growth is
proportional to the size that is
constant exponential growth but if the
rate of growth the percentage increase
is proportional to size
um that actually fits a hyperbolic curve
that goes infinite in finite time so
obviously that can't continue and in
fact around 1960 that relationship
between population size and population
growth rate uh broke uh and and
population growth rates leveled off and
in fact they're decreasing since about
the late 1960s so in a sense economic
growth is no longer dependent on
population size oh I don't think we can
say that necessarily there's a question
of where does this where does economic
growth come from and so I mentioned Chad
Jones earlier so a lot of his work is
essentially contending that uh economic
growth so technological growth and
advancement is uh driven by essentially
the amount of resources that we put into
it and in fact that we have to if we
want to keep exponential growth going in
technological advancement that we have
to put in exponentially moral resources
in other words we have to also have
exponential growth in the amount of
resources we're devoting to r d
and that means not only money for
equipment and everything but also people
in the 20th century we were able to
sustain a pretty rapid exponential
growth in r d in part because we were
educating more people and we were
bringing a greater portion of the
population into r d but that obviously
has limits within population itself at a
certain point you know if your
population doesn't grow and you're
trying to grow your research Workforce
eventually everybody in the world 100 of
the population is you know a PhD
educated uh scientist researching and
trying to push the frontier forward
right and then like at that point if
your population isn't growing if indeed
your population is leveling off or
shrinking which is the best you know the
UN sort of estimates of world population
for the 21st century have it doing you
know then then you might be in trouble
for sustained growth
um unless of course you have some way of
massively leveraging
um you know human r d inputs say perhaps
through AI yeah and we're going to talk
about that in depth later but at first
let's get to your flywheel metaphor you
have the central metaphor you use to
describe what you found out about
progress what do you mean by by
flywheels in this context
um so I mean a flywheel is a metaphor
for anything that has a lot of inertia
that feeds on itself where so I mean
like I said with with progress where um
sort of progress compounds and the more
of it we have made the faster we can
make it I mean it's a similar thing with
a flywheel the faster it's spinning
right the easier it is to keep it
spinning or get it going faster a
flywheel has a lot of inertia so it's
very difficult to get going in the
beginning if you push on a flywheel you
know you can get it going very fast but
only through many many turns in the
beginning it's very hard to turn and
then the faster it goes the easier it is
to turn right and eventually it builds
up you know and once it gets going it's
on it's Unstoppable or at least it's
it's not stoppable immediately it takes
a long time for it to wind down uh I use
that metaphor for Progress it was very
difficult to get progress going in the
beginning why well you know think about
uh uh uh you know why did a
hunter-gatherer tribe not you know why
did most of them for thousands and tens
of thousands of years not invent
agriculture or you know smelting of
metal or you know any of a number of
other of ancient Technologies well I
mean they didn't have a lot of surplus
and you know for the same uh by the same
token you might ask why didn't folks in
the Middle Ages you know in the in the
Early Middle Ages why didn't they invent
the plow for you know or even or the or
the spinning wheel for the longest time
right and even then once we had those
things why didn't they mechanize like we
did later in the industrial revolution
well at any given point you can sort of
say first off it wasn't a lot of surplus
wealth to put into r d whether that
means funding an individual to do it
full time or even maybe somebody who has
like spare time to Tinker and invent
right there wasn't a lot of Base
technology to build stuff with
um maybe there wasn't a lot of great
metal working technology so it's hard to
make machines out of metal which means
it's hard to make high precision
machines
um which which means it's hard to to
automate a lot of stuff even if you made
something it would be hard for for there
to be a market for it so suppose you
invented some great agricultural machine
suppose you were a Millwright you know
who were kind of the the most you know
skilled Engineers of the of the medieval
period I suppose you were a really a
genius Millwright and you invented some
amazing piece of agricultural Machinery
well who could you sell it to there
wasn't a way to create a market much
beyond your town or Village
uh because we didn't have the
transportation technology and the
communication technology we didn't have
newspapers and railroads and so forth to
advertise your product and then take
orders and then ship you know product
all over the place so you didn't have a
national Market or even a regional
market you had like a very local market
and so um you know small Market sizes
because of low connectivity of the human
race meant that there was just uh you
couldn't there wasn't a lot of
opportunity to um to you know to to make
something that had a high investment
cost a high invention cost and then
leverage that through a large Market
because markets were small if you made
some I mean in the era before printing
or for that matter before written
language if you made some great
discovery how could you even tell people
about it right word didn't travel until
uh you know we got like the Royal
Society which set up and the the uh the
what do they call the Republic of
letters where you know these sort of uh
scientists and other
um you know natural philosophers were
like literally writing letters to each
other and then the the transactions of
the Royal Society could print them those
in a you know a proto-journal because we
had the printing press and so forth in
all of these Technologies
um and advances and social advancement
um too right all of these things uh so I
mean by the way if you wanted to if you
if you did have an invention and you
wanted to try to sell it and propagate
it when could you create a corporation
corporate the corporate form if you
wanted to raise investment from a lot of
investors the corporate form was not
common until like the 19th century so I
mean it's a long it has a complicated
history but like
um certainly there were some there were
some uh by the seven there are
significant corporations by the 17th
century
um but it was it was difficult to get a
corporation for a long time for a lot of
that history it required like an act of
parliament or or something right so it
wasn't until the 19th century that you
could form a corporation by right
um just by filing some papers like we're
kind of used to doing today anyway I've
gotten deep into this but basically all
of this every time we come up with some
fundamental Advance like writing or
printing or the internet or uh you know
better transportation or um corporate
you know corporate law or machine tools
or metal working or the scientific
method you know or anything like that
these things contribute you to make all
of progress faster so you can think of
whenever we come up with some
fundamental Advance like that that makes
everything faster or that specifically
makes
um progress you know r d faster that
increments the exponent at which we are
making exponential progress that is the
flywheel in the sense that there's
inertia because it's difficult to get
the flywheel going what about the
flywheel going on itself after it's been
brought to a certain speed so is there
also is that also part of the metaphor
yeah in the sense that Society all it
too has a certain momentum and even
today in the you know even in the late
20th and into the 21st century in a
world where we are many people are very
um skeptical of the very idea of
progress and very fearful and you know
doubtful of it a lot of progress just
goes forward because there's so much
Social momentum behind it because there
is a university system and there are
research labs and there are Venture
capitalists and they're you know and
there's a market and there are engineers
and inventors and you know and so forth
right um because there are all of those
things all those institutions formal and
informal uh progress continues so I read
that you've recently been convinced that
there is in fact a great stagnation in
growth perhaps you could uh explain what
that is and then explain how that might
fit into the to the flywheel metaphor is
is the flywheels so to speak slowing
down certainly so uh again you know a
flywheel has a lot of momentum but it's
not Unstoppable if you leave it alone it
might slow down a little bit just from
friction and of course if you actively
begin to resist it it will start to slow
down even if imperceptibly at first
um so yes uh in terms of technological
stagnation this is something that people
have been talking about at least since
the 2010s you know Peter Thiel is one of
the earliest to start talking about it
Tyler Cowan wrote a book The Great
stagnation which I think came out in
um so pretty early in 2015 or so Robert
Gordon came out with this book the rise
and fall of American growth where he
um argued that you know America growth
in the US had slowed down over the last
you know 50 to 75 years
and so I started out my investigation of
progress not even really knowing much
about this hypothesis when I first heard
about it I was somewhat skeptical and
eventually just through studying the
history of progress I came around to uh
to agreeing that there has been a
Slowdown in at least economic growth
over the Latin technological progress
over the last uh yeah 50 years or so uh
this is not to say anything necessarily
about scientific progress I'm really
talking about
um progress has manifested in the
economy so technology and and Industrial
progress this is also not a prediction
for the future I'm not saying that
segnation is any kind of inevitable um
nor is it a diagnosis of the cause it's
just sort of looking at certain symptoms
that we can see over historically in the
rear view mirror over the last 50 years
and I think the simple so you know you
can look at uh metrics like um GDP
growth or tfp growth tfp being something
called total Factor productivity which
is kind of a metric that economists
generally use to um to have an estimate
of technological uh progress manifested
in the economy
you can look at those numbers and those
things certainly tell the story they
have slowed down you can look at it more
qualitatively as well so uh you know one
reason why people are often skeptical of
this idea of a Slowdown is because they
look back at the last 50 years and they
see
a remarkable amount of progress
computers and the internet have you know
have have progressed extremely fast over
the last 50 75 years plus you know we've
gotten it was just under 50 years ago
that we got for instance recombinant DNA
and so all of genetic engineering you
know has from from uh you know synthetic
insulin all the way up to mRNA vaccines
has you know has has kind of taken that
so you know there have been one or two
major fundamental revolutions
technological Revolutions in the last 50
years
um but look back at the period from say
um the 50-year period from say 1870 to
1920.
um so roughly the 50-year period ending
about 100 years ago well that period
also had a revolution in information and
Communications uh because it's all the
invention of the telephone and radio
that period also had a revolution in
biology called The Germ Theory and the
beginnings of its implementation in
public health and us and see very
significant declines in mortality from
infectious disease as we got better
Water Sanitation and new vaccines and so
forth
and then on top of that it had a
revolution in energy with the
development of the electricity uh the
the electrical industry uh right
generators and motors and electric
lights and so forth it had another
revolution in energy with the invention
and and deployment of the internal
combustion engine which led to
Revolution in transportation with the
invention of the end of the automobile
and the airplane and then it had a
revolution in applied chemistry which
gave us things like so the synthetic
materials like the first Plastics such
as Bakelite and the first uh synthetic
fertilizer through the hobberbosh
process
so all the types of progress that we've
had in the last 50 years were going on
in that period and then we also got
progress in energy manufacturing
Transportation uh and and construction
and so
um you know the recent developments just
don't stack up you can argue that the
internet is you know freaking amazing
and it totally is and I don't want to
dismiss or downplay it as some people do
you can argue that it's at least as big
maybe bigger than telephone and radio
combined but I think it's hard to argue
that it's bigger than telephone radio
electricity internal combustion oil the
automobile the airplane you know plastic
and fertilizer right it's just there's
just too many things that stack up the
argument becomes untenable at a certain
point so yes I think there was more
progress in the 1870s 1920 period than
in the 1970s to 2020 period And I I yeah
so I I think you can see that now to be
clear there was more progress 1970 to
2020 than at any 50-year period before
the Industrial Revolution right stay
Nation doesn't mean zero progress it
just means a relative slowdown to what
came before yeah it makes sense you um
you mentioned the importance of the
Industrial Revolution when talking about
the history of progress so here we're
talking about one very large Factor uh
that that has a lot of explanatory power
when we're talking about
um historical progress does it make
sense to look for the main cause of
progress whether that be population size
or energy use or ideas or intelligence
um is that something you you're you're
looking into or that you're interested
in when I got interested in progress and
decided to start a blog about it I
called it the roots of progress and that
was for a reason I wanted to find and
understand that ultimately the deepest
causes of progress I knew that the way
there was to start by understanding
things at the object level and to build
up to a bigger and deeper understanding
right not to sort of to try to jump to
Grand theories right away and that's why
I've spent a lot of time way down in the
weeds of the history of progress before
you can even explain progress you have
to sort of know what is there to be
explained and I think even that is not
part of a basic education today as it
should be that's a separate topic uh so
yes I am interested does it make sense
to talk about the one cause
I think if you want a very full Rich
thorough understanding of progress you
want to understand all the different
causes that operate at different levels
and you want to understand what levels
there they operate at and and what the
relationship between all of them is and
yet some of them are more fundamental
than others
um but I think if you only knew about
one cause no matter which one it was you
would have an impoverished picture of
you know the full story right that makes
sense I was thinking whether we could
zoom in on one factor that perhaps
explained 70 or 80 percent of the
progress we're seeing do you think
that's the case again it matters a lot
what level you're talking about so at a
certain level what happened with the
Industrial Revolution and the whole
Industrial Age is just the high level
pattern that I was talking about that
applies to all of human history which is
that progress compounds what's
interesting about the Industrial
Revolution is that it was something of
an inflection point and I think there
are a few things that you can see you
know that that kind of you know why why
was it an interesting inflection point
why did it why did why did it sort of
kick us into a new mode of production
you can understand that on a few levels
I think you know one important level to
understand it on is
um sort of the the fundamental economic
importance of energy and Manufacturing
that's really the that's really where
that's what the Industrial Revolution
was about it was a it was mostly about
energy and Manufacturing right and then
I think the other thing the other
lens on it is that I do believe the
Industrial Revolution was ultimately a
product of the Enlightenment and that
means it was a product of certain ideas
uh ultimately philosophical ideas ways
of looking at the world ways of thinking
and ultimately you know political
structures as well
I think those are probably the two most
important ways to see it so we have
we've talked about progress especially
technological progress and
we at the future of Life Institute we're
very interested in the relationship
between technological progress and risk
so do do you have a sense of of whether
we have a good model of how
technological progress goes together
with risk
I can say about it I don't think we have
I mean you say a good model I don't
think we have very good models I
certainly I haven't really looked for it
but I haven't seen anything that an
economist would call a model like a
formal mathematical model or anything
um you know like we like we do have for
economic growth itself right we have
some pretty good models of economic
growth not perfect there's things they
don't ex they can't explain everything
but they can explain a lot
I haven't seen even an attempt at that
with risk
um it would be very interesting to to
try to do I think just from looking at
the history of progress and risk we can
you know say a few high-level things I
think it's certainly true that that
progress overall
um decreases at least day-to-day risk or
even year-to-year risk for individuals
um and you can see that just in
mortality rates so the long-term decline
of mortality rates is one of the big
stories of progress again we don't have
um we don't have very good mortality
figures they go back much more than a
century or two but just from the last
you know at least century and a half two
centuries or so
um in some places I think in Sweden they
go back to Mid 1700s so maybe we got up
to about 300 years or so you can see
very long-term you know very consistent
declines in mortality a lot of that was
from infectious disease but not all of
it
um some of it is from uh accidents some
of it is from violence you know and so
forth now I think you could make an
argument that you know advanced
technology increases a certain sort of
tail risk that maybe our day-to-day risk
gets lower uh but there's an increased
risk of some you know massive blow up
certainly you know when you look at the
history of War you know
it's a little hard to tell like maybe
war is getting sort of less destructive
overall or maybe it's we just having
more infrequent Wars that are like
exponentially bigger you know and you
could say this a similar thing about um
about other kinds of catastrophes
not sure whether that is correct overall
but it's an argument that you could
certainly make and have some
plausibility to it do you think we would
have trouble developing a formal model
of the relationship between risk and
progress because risk is perhaps very
difficult to measure I'm not an expert
in creating such models I read I read
academic papers that have those models
in them but if I were to try to create
one I would be uh very much a novice but
I would imagine that where you might
start is with the data that we do have
on mortality statistics right that's
that's sort of the most straightforward
uh probably you know it's probably where
you're going to find the best data it's
the most obvious thing death statistics
are sort of the are going to be the most
accurate the hardest to fake that's
probably where I would start
can you can you model mortality raids
and maybe model it in different you know
times and places and for different
demographics and for different causes
and um how would that fit different
models that's perhaps an increase in
large scale risks from from war you
mentioned do you think that also goes
for risks such as pandemics or nuclear
war certainly there's no risk of nuclear
war before nuclear weapons existed
another is so like that has obviously
increased pandemics yeah the risk of
that has probably increased
um one because we're just a much more
connected society and two because uh you
know we have like bio research now um
which could which could accidentally
create or sometimes deliberately create
um you know lethal pathogens so um I
mean at the same time we have a lot of
um we also have a lot of technology to
to defeat pandemics there has been
nothing as bad as you know the 1918 flu
even though the world is much more
connected right I mean covid was not as
bad as the as the 1918 flu even though
the world is much more connected now and
you know that's for a lot of reasons
right so on the one hand like with you
know airplanes and and all and
everything like the the disease can
spread a lot faster but with the
internet information about the disease
can spread a lot faster and the science
of the disease can progress a lot faster
and we can sequence the DNA of the virus
or the RNA of the virus and we can
instantly publish that and we can even
track the virus around the world by
sequencing uh you know genes from it's
it's its genetic material from different
uh victims and we can create a vaccine
you know right away I mean and so you
know here's the thing in the 1918 flu it
wasn't just the flu it was uh what often
killed you was not the influenza but it
was the subsequent bacterial pneumonia
that you would get once you were your
system was weakened from the Imodium
today we have antibiotics right we could
we would be much less susceptible to an
influenza pneumonia combination like
that and today we have mRNA vaccines and
perhaps in the future we will have broad
spectrum antivirals that are as
effective against you know a broad class
of uh viruses as our current antibiotics
are effective against you know many
different bacteria
um and maybe we'll have uh you know far
UVC light sanitizing the atmosphere at
least indoors
um so that these things don't spread so
much indoors and maybe you know well
there's all sorts of things maybe we'll
have Wastewater monitoring so that we
can detect these things much faster
right so I suspect that what happens is
that we go through peaks of
vulnerability
um so vulnerability ramps up as maybe
technology creates risk and then it
rests back down again as more technology
decreases the risk you see this with for
instance
um uh you know car car accidents and
Road deaths the the road deaths
um as uh even in absolute numbers or
even as a you know or or per per capita
uh in the U.S they they ramped up as
more people were driving and then they
peaked in the middle of 20th century and
then they've been coming down um ever
since
um even even in absolute numbers uh Road
deaths are on a long-term decline
even as the population grows and as
vehicle miles traveled grows even faster
you know that's probably the high level
thing I would um I would look at and I
enroll existential risk I think you know
most people who think deeply about this
would probably say yeah in the future we
are going to be much less vulnerable in
fact perhaps now is a uniquely
vulnerable time right so maybe we're
somewhere near the peak of that risk
curve if we look historically can we say
anything in general about how the pace
of development of a given technology has
an impact on the safety of that
technology I don't know if the pace of
development per se is the best thing to
look at one of the things that jumps out
to me the most is that some of the worst
risks are the ones where we just
literally didn't have the knowledge to
even anticipate them
an example that comes to mind is x-rays
so when X-rays were discovered people
had no idea they were harmful and they
would x-ray their hands you know people
would go get an x-ray of their own
bodies as like a novelty at parties for
fun you know with like no shielding and
um x-ray technicians actually when they
were setting up a machine to to make
sure it was working properly they would
do an x-ray of their hand you know and
then a lot of these guys ended up
getting severe damage um to their hands
some of them had to have their hands
amputated and so forth was quite common
so this was uh you know and I mean
people died from experimenting with with
this stuff and you know you think about
it
this rate you know this radiation
phenomenon like
you can't see it you can't hear it you
can't feel it you can't detect it in
almost any way it's this like
ghostly ethereal thing that seems to
have like very little contact with like
the material world how could it possibly
hurt you right like nobody could really
anticipated that
so that's the kind of thing you know
just like it's the unknown unknowns that
are really the worst what are some other
I mean I'm just I'm kind of thinking
about this in real time because I
haven't I haven't analyzed this this
question so I'm just trying to pull up
some relevant examples and think about
them right I mean automobiles are a good
example right so like early automobiles
were pretty dangerous they were slightly
less dangerous in that they didn't CR
they didn't go as fast and people
weren't going as fast on the run the
roads weren't paved so that you couldn't
even you know go very fast but you know
they didn't have there was a they were
missing most safety features right I
mean they had brakes and they had
steering obviously but like short of
that you know they didn't have seat
belts they may I can't remember if they
had horns maybe they're not standard
they didn't have lights to Signal brake
lights turn signals that kind of thing
we didn't have stop lights and you know
uh you know traffic direction that kind
of thing so um
there was all and of course anybody and
everybody would walk in the streets and
horses and children and whatever right
there was no there was no separation so
automobiles was dangerous I mean part of
it was the automobiles were you know
began to be placed in the hands of like
everybody
um so contrast at least with the
railroads you know you had a trained
professional running a locomotive you
know but with automobiles it started to
be like yeah anybody who can buy one can
drive one
um and of course again we didn't have
driver's ed we didn't have driver's
licenses Etc
um there was this sort of widespread
availability and economic incentive for
lots of people to get one another thing
I think about around the same era a
little earlier is
um the the patent medicine industry so
around the very late 19th century into
the early 20th
uh the medical industry like the drug
industry was just absolutely full of
Shams and fraud and there's a lot of
stuff that was you know at best at best
completely ineffective and often
actually quite harmful some of it
containing large amounts of alcohol or
even you know
toxic stuff and I think a significant
part of what drove that was a
combination of
a lot of people really really wanted
solutions to their medical problems
and we literally didn't have any like
the drug actually working drugs had not
yet been discovered and so people
grasped at anything they could find they
were willing to take something that was
completely ineffective because literally
nobody was offering them anything that
was effective
um and so you know there are various
reasons why
um how that problem got solved part of
the way it got solved was like we
clamped down on false advertising and on
you know true demanded truth in labeling
and you know that kind of thing and just
you know you know word word spread but
part of what actually happened also was
that we discovered actually working
drugs you know and then people could
take those instead
so those are a few things kind of off
the top of my head a few lessons that we
might be able to draw from a few case
studies but it's again it's not obvious
to me that sort of pace of development
is a highly meaningful variable or
something or or like a highly correlated
one but I just I just haven't thought
about it that deeply in terms of kind of
looking at the case studies or or really
analyzed it you've been working a bit on
a philosophy of safety at least you have
a post on this and one of your main
points here is to say that safety is
actually part of progress at least
historically speaking so perhaps you
could tell us about that I think it's a
mistake to think of safety and progress
as something that are sort of opposed to
each other again come back to drugs
right
drugs now are much you know the drugs on
the market are much much safer than they
used to be part of the reason for that
is that we do clinical trials and we
have a very careful you know testing
regime
um and then after we do the trials to
make sure a new
chemical is uh is safe and effective we
also have a very careful manufacturing
processes to make sure that as we
manufacture the drug we're actually
making the thing that we think we're
making and it's not getting contaminated
you know with with dangerous things and
so forth
all of that adds overhead
and surely more drugs would be released
onto the market if we didn't you know
test them so carefully before we
released them right
but I think it would be a little
ridiculous to claim that the
introduction of clinical trials was
something that was opposed to progress
or that you know harmed progress in
pharmaceutical industry it was something
that contributed to progress in the
pharmaceutical industry because we don't
just want any old drugs flooding the
market right we actually want safe
effective drugs
you know when you think about progress
progress is ultimately getting us more
of what we want as human beings and what
we want is is safe effective drugs not
random you know dangerous drugs and so
the introduction of clinical trials even
if it decreased to the number of new
drugs or increased the cost of getting
them out if it's a good trade-off right
if it's cost effective if it's a
cost-effective safety measure then it
actually buys us something that we want
for a cost we're willing to pay and
that's progress that's what I mean when
I say that you know and again I mean
automobiles are surely more expensive
than they would be if they didn't have
any of the safety features that they
have
but that doesn't mean that the
introduction of those features was
somehow a reversal of progress in the
automotive industry right it was a part
of progress in automotive industry uh it
contributed to that progress we have
better you know safer cars or better
cars even if they're a bit more
expensive again as long as the cost uh
benefit trade-off is worth it yeah
there's a case to be made that we are
over cautious and we over regulate some
areas perhaps air travel and we are
under cautious and we we under regulate
other areas such as maybe biological
Labs do you have any any ideas why we
might both over regulate and under
regulate at the same time in different
areas I mean this phenomenon is very
common I mean it happens even within uh
you know one agency right so like um
Scott Alexander has written a lot about
the FDA in the US and you know he points
out that the FDA is too strict about
some drugs and like not or treatments
and not strict enough about others so it
will let through occasionally drugs that
you know that don't even work super well
like the Alzheimer's one that I can
never remember how to pronounce educonan
the map or something like that
um and then uh and then maybe they they
take a long long time to approve
something that maybe should have gotten
approved a lot earlier overall Alex
tabarok makes the argument that they're
that on balanced they're actually way
too strict
um but in something that doesn't mean
that you know everything they every
decision they make is there for like two
straight right yeah why does this happen
I mean I certainly think visibility is a
big part of it air safety is very
visible when a plane crashes it makes
the news bio lab leaks are not very
visible most people don't even know that
they happen terrorism is extremely
visible right and so we over we
overcompensate for like terrorist
attacks
um in terms of that security and then
you know maybe we under compensate for
lab leagues that kind of thing
um so you know visibility is a is is a
big part of it so part of it has to do
with kind of sins of omission versus
sins of commission right so we set up
agencies whose job is to regulate it or
to provide us with safety and
um maybe those agencies are structured
in a certain way like a regulatory
agency like the FDA or the the NRC the
nuclear commission is set up to review
and approve all you know new things of a
certain type
and um and so one problem with that
structure is that it creates very
one-sided incentives because anything
that gets approved and and turned out to
be bad or creates you know creates harm
the agency might get blamed for for
badly approving
if it gets approved and it doesn't
create harm mostly nobody notices that
they did a good job of approving it if
they fail to approve something that
would have created great good well also
no that's also invisible right and
nobody sees that so really you know so
they kind of get no credit for approving
good things
um they get blamed if they approve bad
things and they don't get blamed if they
fail to approve good things and so you
just get all the incentives are towards
being too strict and so you get
um what I described in a recent essay as
this kind of regulatory ratchet where um
anytime anything bad happens the rules
get stricter and that's a pretty much a
one-way Street and so you just end up
with this morass of um of of regulations
you end up with a regulatory Overkill
and I think that's a very common pattern
you write that safety requires defense
in depth what is defense in depth and
perhaps we could take an example where
we where we talk about how it might work
yeah sure I mean defense in depth just
means you have many layers of things you
don't count on any one mechanism as a
silver bullet to create safety a safety
is created by attacking the problem from
many different angles so do you have
some sort of redundancy in the in the
safety features so come back to you know
come back to automobiles we have seat
belts and anti-lock brakes and
collapsible steering columns and crumple
zones and shatterproof glass and we have
um you know turn signals and brake
lights and headlights and uh we have
um you know Traffic Systems and we have
divided highways and overpasses
um and and underpasses and and on-ramps
um and we have traffic lights and stop
signs and we have social mechanisms like
we have driver's education and driver's
licensing and we have social you know
stigma campaigns Against Drunk Driving
and uh and you know and we have airbags
and we have all these things so you just
you some of them are are literal and
sort of inventions
um some of them are inventions to
prevent accidents some make accidents
less damaging like a seat belt or an
airbag some of them are um are in the
systems rather that you know like the
the road system rather than the vehicle
itself some of them are about the driver
some of them are social some of them are
legal some of them are moral
um so you add up all of these things and
it's all of them put together that um
that that create Road Safety that's
defense in depth another metaphor is the
Swiss Cheese model or any piece of Swiss
cheese is going to have some holes but
if you take a bunch of you know a bunch
of pieces where the the holes are not
correlated and you stack them up then
there's no one spot where you can
penetrate the whole thing right where
there's a hole that goes all the way
through and so any basically it's a
recognition that any safety mechanism is
going to be imperfect and incomplete and
so the only way you get anything
approaching acceptable safety is to
layer you know multiple of them combine
multiple of them in a system do you
think we can predict in advance which
Technologies might become dangerous so
that we can develop these safety
features and we can think about defense
in depth well sure I mean to some extent
they're always unknown unknowns and
there's always errors in prediction you
know we can and do very often anticipate
risk
it can sometimes be hard to tell you
know the difference between true risk
and um
you know people who are just uh kind of
worried about new technology or or or
are opposing it and are looking for
arguments and maybe there isn't even a
very a sharp line to be drawn between
them
18 go go to look at 1820s England right
or Britain it was you it's hard to find
a more pro-progress time or place these
people erected a statue to James Watt
and called him you know like a
benefactor of the world
and yet at the same time you look what
was going on well the big development
that everybody was talking about and
hadn't quite yet happened was railroads
and you get people writing about
railroads and saying these things can
never be safe there's no way I mean come
on you're saying you know some people
were proposing that the locomotives
might travel faster than stage coaches
and you get people saying come on
there's no way that could possibly be
safe you've got 10 tons of iron
barreling down a track at what 18 19 20
miles an hour
come on right I mean this is literally
this is literally how people were
thinking and uh in fact there was one
writer um who said uh that you know
basically hoped that Parliament would
come to its senses and pass a law
limiting uh locomotives to a speed of
eight or nine miles an hour which
obviously was the maximum that could
possibly be safe
so there's always these kind of worries
and sometimes they're even correct and
you know from a certain angle were we
correct to worry about train wrecks
absolutely there were lots of train
wrecks uh it was a very real safety
issue and it wasn't hard to see that but
it was also wrong to say that eight or
nine miles was like the maximum safe
speed uh and that we should just limit
things to that and if we had done that
it would have been you know very bad for
the economic development of the world
going forward so yeah it's always
possible to and and by the way even
before uh you know even before railroads
became a big thing
um people were starting to recognize
some of the
um safety and even the pollution
problems so um
in uh in 1829 there was a famous contest
held called the rain Hill trials to uh
test a bunch of locomotive engines
against each other try to figure out
whether there was any engine that was
ready to actually work a passenger
railroad which none had yet done
and in this uh contest they stipulated a
couple of things
um one thing they stipulated was that if
I'm recalling this correctly that uh
there had to be pressure valves on the
boiler to uh to make sure that you
didn't get a boiler explosion from a
buildup of too much pressure and in fact
they'd already started to learn about
the human factors
um it turns out the engineers uh so the
hardest people to convince to um to to
go along with safety measures are like
the workers themselves whose lives are
in danger
um so it turned Engineers running these
locomotives um they were being run for
cargo and like coal mines and stuff like
that and the engineers you know if the
if the pressure valve would go off
sometimes they would just like hold it
down because they didn't believe they
basically didn't believe in the pressure
valve the the rules of this contest if I
recall correctly stipulated that it had
they had to have at least one pressure
valve that was Out Of Reach of the
engineer so that he couldn't go hold it
down
and then another thing that they
stipulated was that
um the machines basically were not
allowed to emit smoke
um so either they had to somehow consume
their own smoke or they had to which
they all did they had to burn
um smokeless fuel
um such as a purified form of coal known
as Coke
so in fact all these engines in the in
the contest burnt Coke because they
didn't want to create smoke
um and that was a that was actually part
of the law I think when Parliament
allowed passed a whatever an act
allowing this railroad to get created
they said but you're not allowed to
create a whole bunch of smoke inside so
already people were thinking about some
of the safety and environmental issues
so I think the reality you know and that
was 200 years ago that was in a time
that was way way less safety conscious
than we are today and it was in a world
where there was just objectively much
riskier where the background risk that
everybody faced every day was was much
higher you could catch you know cholera
or malaria any day and be dead in a week
um at any age at any time of life right
no matter how healthy you were so I
think yeah people always do anticipate
to some extent what some of the risks
and problems might be and often try to
compensate for them but how much they do
that and what the incentives are and
what the the rules are I mean that
varies over by by time and place so one
of the main points in your philosophy of
safety is that getting to safety or
getting safe technology does not require
a sacrificing progress but you also
mentioned a couple of of instances where
it might make sense to slow down the
progress technological progress in
certain areas in order to to let safety
catch up for example when it comes to
genetic engineering how widespread is
this phenomena where we might want to
slow down in order for safety to to
catch up and are there perhaps also
Technologies where we would like to
Institute an indefinite ban such as for
example gain of function research so
first off I mean when you talk about
slowing down I think it's what's
important to the way it's important to
conceptualize it is that we are if we're
slowing down progress we're slowing down
one dimension of progress but if we
think about the total package what we
care about is actually again so like if
we go back to what I said about drugs
right we're maybe we're slowing down the
rate of introduction of new molecules
onto the market that's one dimension of
progress but we're not slowing down the
overall progress of the pharmaceutical
industry by introducing clinical trials
and I don't think we slow down the
overall progress of uh the of genetic
engineering by pausing you know certain
types of experiments for eight months
until we could create until we could do
the asilamar conference of 1975 where
they got together to decide on safety
practices again not a few not if you add
up the total picture of of what do we
actually want to do
um that's why again I think we have to
we have to think about integrating
safety into an overall program of
progress it isn't integral part now uh
you uh so then the other question you
asked was are there some technologies
that we should ban such as gain of
function I don't consider gain a
function to be a technology I consider
it to be a research Avenue or a is a
type of experiment that we run I'm not
an expert on this but I'm certainly uh I
am inclined to believe from what I have
heard that there are certain types of
experiments along these lines that we
should not do the term gain of function
might not be the best term to describe
them I'm not sure if we have the right
term for them I would just say like just
go uh listen to the interviews that
Kevin S Felt has given on this topic I
think he's very smart and uh and has
very good judgment on this and and I'm
basically willing to sort of go along
with whatever he says is best given
given what I've heard from him and he
certainly believes that um there are
certain types of experiments yeah where
we literally try to make viruses more
dangerous
um that we should not do actually even
more to the point one of asphalt's
points is that not only do we try to
make sort of viruses dangerous or to
identify which ones would would uh
potentially create lethal pandemics but
then people are encouraged to publish
this and even to make create ranked
lists of viruses you know by how
dangerous would they be which is just
giving putting weapons in the hands of
bioterrorists right or or foreign
bioweapons programs for basically no
gain
um there's a theory that we gain from
this because by identifying the
pathogens ahead of time we can be ready
for them but I don't think there's any
evidence that we're actually doing that
certainly we weren't ready for covid
when it hit and being ready for it
wasn't you know or like having knowledge
about coronaviruses in particular wasn't
what allowed us to combat them what
allowed this to combat them was very
rapid response platforms so the fact
that we had invested for decades into
mRNA vaccine technology was what allowed
us to write not to mention all of the
underlying more you know broad enabling
Technologies like genetic sequencing and
genetic uh you know Printing and so
forth right
it was that it was those General
capabilities and that rapid response
platform that allowed us to be covet not
some foreknowledge of the particular
virus that was going to come along so um
yeah I certainly think when there is a
relatively delimited or narrow area of
research that creates particular uh
unacceptable risks and which is not
generating anything like proportional
gain and whether and when there are
other ways to sort of learn the key
things that we need to learn you know
it's not as if we're cutting off a whole
area of biological knowledge uh by by
restricting these experiments then yeah
we shouldn't we shouldn't do them right
there's um there's some things that are
too dangerous to do and that aren't you
know you always have to apply cost
benefit analysis to these things just uh
if we're speculating here do you think
there are there are technologies that
are so difficult to handle or dangerous
intrinsically that that we should not go
near them or or because it seems a
little suspiciously lucky that that all
Technologies turn out to be controllable
by us with enough experience and
experimentation and trial and error and
so on do you think there are areas of
science or technology where it would be
ill-advised for us to go yeah so first I
don't think it's luck I think it's the
nature of human problem solving
that we can conquer pretty much anything
given you know sufficient compounded
intelligence and and work and research
on the problem
are there any technologies that might be
just too dangerous I think it depends
how broadly or narrowly you're defining
technology there are certain things that
we ban or that are extremely you know
limited uh I don't I can't I don't can't
name off the top of my head but right I
mean there are chemicals that are just
too dangerous to be handled right and
they're certainly there are viruses that
you know maybe like smallpox that would
be better off if we just just literally
destroyed all of them even the last
remaining stores and some you know
research facility somewhere right Etc
and somehow screw up the genetic
sequence of smallpox off the internet
see I'd be much more hesitant about that
well if the internet maybe I would I
would be much I would be very hesitant
to destroy it from all of Humanity's
records that would be an irretrievable
loss of information right
um I don't know I'd have to hear
arguments pro and con there I'm not I'm
not ready to say we should do that uh
scrub it off the internet yeah it might
be I might be good with that right
classified dangerous information that
kind of thing I mean I also I'm also
partial to I mean to go back to Kevin
sveld he's got this program called
secure DNA where the the ultimate goal
of the program is to make it impossible
for anybody to just print any known
dangerous uh pathogen or you know
anything that is like too very similar
to uh to essential pathitude if you you
if you Define technology very broadly
like oh is artificial intelligence just
too dangerous and we should never build
it or is you know genetic engineering
it
I haven't seen any technology at that
level where I think yeah we just need to
cut off this entire branch of the tech
tree because the whole thing is too
dangerous
I mean I wouldn't say that can never
ever happen and I can prove to you now
that it'll never come about but I
haven't seen it yet and I would my
default assumption for anything at that
at that level of generality would be
that we can find good ways to use it you
have an essay in which you sketch out
four different perspectives on AI risks
and I I found this very useful I I read
this essay as being sort of ordered in
in order of perceived risk so when you
go down the list as I'm about to go to
go you the the risk kind of increases so
the the first the first one the first
perspective from which we can view AI is
that it is software and as with all
software it has books and but we can we
can solve these books second is that AI
is a complex system and it's it can fail
in in ways that are difficult to predict
like for example we saw the financial
system do in in 2008 and third one is
that that AI is a is a is becoming or
perhaps on the verge of becoming a
powerful agent with misaligned interests
and that seems pretty difficult to
control and and the the fourth one is
that is that AI is is becoming a
secondary Advanced species with per and
and there it seems almost
yeah at a very difficult problem
um where do you where do you fold
yourself how do you see AI risk I think
that we are certainly
um it will certainly have complex system
type failures
and even you know some sort of principal
agent problems I think we've already
seen evidence of principal agent
problems for instance in the documented
instances of reward hacking and you
might explain what a principal agent
problem is sure the principal agent
problem is just at any time uh you the
principal delegate to some agent to do
something for you it's just hard to
align your interests the the agent is
ultimately acting in their interest for
their goals and no matter how hard you
try it's hard to get those goals to be
your goals so you know think of a
company that employs uh you know that
employs people
um so you have a you have a company you
have workers and the company tries to
set up a reward structure where they
promote people for you know for for
doing good things and then what you find
is in any such system uh people start to
game the system and they start to work
for the letter of the reward structure
rather than the spirit of it right and
so
um if uh you know so one famous thing
that happens in technology companies is
if you're a product manager to get
promoted you have to create and launch a
new product you know to get promoted
Beyond a certain level from senior to
like super senior or whatever I don't
know and uh and so then what do you find
well you find lots of people uh you find
the company launches too many products
and that after launch those products are
not you know maintained and and uh and
cared for with as much love right and so
like this is one uh very plausible
hypothesis for why does Google launch so
many products often overlapping with and
competing with each other and then often
shut them down some years later right
well one argument is there's internal
pressure for this to happen because the
PMS want to get promoted and so they
create new products you know for their
own sake even though it's even though
it's not really what's in the best
interest of the company overall many
many examples of you know I mean this is
just sort of good heart's law whenever a
measure becomes a Target it ceases to be
a good measure and so if you try to
measure if you the principal try to
measure what's good for you and set that
up as a target for the agent it ceases
to be a good measure uh
um so these sorts of things happen all
the time
and you know given that they they happen
you know so frequently I think it would
be you know it's not at all surprising
that we'll get some of this with AI
agents right
so you know I believe those things I am
much more skeptical of the you know new
intelligent species analogy I'm even
more skeptical of the
um Clash of civilizations analogy where
you think if it's like oh this is like
you know when Western uh Empires met
with less technologically advanced
civilizations or if we had an alien
invasion you know and they were at
another technological level right um I
don't think that analogy really applies
at all Homo sapiens are evolving in the
context of you know amid neanderthals
like maybe that's a somewhat better
analogy but even that is not perfect so
um I'm kind of less uh I I think those
analogies are much more speculative
yeah and for listeners interested in the
full argument for why AI might become a
analogous to a separate Advanced species
they can go back and listen to the
podcast I did with Dan Hendricks in this
feed so we we have the principal agent
problem as you talked about and in some
sense companies are quite intelligent
they they have resources to make sure
that the employees of those companies do
as as the company as is in the in the
interest of the company in the case of
AI we are the principal and and the
agent is the AI but but what if the
agent grows to become more intelligent
than the principle will it still be
controllable like I certainly see the
argument for why you know it would be
difficult to control
I'm not convinced that we can't
find some way to do it
so I I mean I think I think a number of
different Futures are open and um I can
imagine a future in which
AI essentially remains a tool
and if that is somehow impossible I can
imagine a future in which
AI becomes autonomous
but still coexists peacefully and
productively with us
or and I would
I mean possibly and I would count this
as not as good you know a future in
which we basically get taken care of
like pets which you know I mean any dog
or cat has a much better life
um than it as a human pet than it could
ever have on its own right I don't know
it's again we're getting into like
uh uh we're getting into things where
all of our conclusions are based on
thought experiments and pretty high
level analogies and I just think we have
to be extremely wary about drawing too
much of a conclusion from that type of
reasoning
do you think that that people disagree
about AI risk because they anchor on
different analogies so perhaps so we we
have we have two eminent AI scientists
uh Geoffrey Hinson and and janakun
perhaps John lacun thinks of AI risks in
the in the sense of from the perspective
of AI as software with books whereas
perhaps Geoffrey Hinson thinks of it
more in the sense of the Advent the
advance of a new uh separate species do
you think do you think that that
analogies play a large role in the
disagreement here yeah yeah I think they
do in part because again that's kind of
all we have to go on I mean think there
are many many reasons for why people
disagree right they can be I mean they
can be engaging in motivated reasoning
because they have some prior conclusion
they want to protect they can um they
can just have some fundamental
philosophical or psychological
difference in temperament as to how
optimistic or pessimistic they are
there's like lots of different reasons
why I mean in an era in a in a field and
on a question where there is so little
to go on where we have no uh empirical
evidence and no formal you know rigorous
mathematical models nothing to really
base a very firm conclusion on and all
we're doing is speculating like it's
very easy for people to reach different
conclusions and which conclusions they
reach are going to be based on
things like their their underlying
temperament or their biases or uh yeah
which analogies they happen to launch
onto yeah I would say we have a little
bit more to go on than that in in
machine learning you you can do
experiments and and see that for example
it can be difficult to specify a reward
in a learning system or that that the
model you're developing might be able to
to hack the reward you've given it and
so on so we we have we have some some
something more than than just an
analogies I would say fair but not
enough to get us to the big conclusions
yeah agreed agreed and so perhaps we
perhaps we should try to get more uh
empirical data to solve this problem
this leads us into into your essay on
solutionism on AI safety so what is what
is solutionism in general and how how do
you see this applying to the AI safety
problem uh solutionism is my you know
Third Way I I tend to hate the discourse
around uh safety and you know other
kinds of technological problems because
it tends to break down into the
complacent optimists versus the
defeatist pessimists right so on on the
one hand the folks who are so
pessimistic that they see no way uh to
solve the problems that they Envision or
that they identify and then on the other
hand the folks who are so optimistic to
the point of complacency where they uh
don't even see the problems or they want
to dismiss the reality of the problems
claim they don't exist claim that
they're trivial claim they'll be easy to
solve claim that they're already solved
Etc and so forth and um I think
problems are often real and the way we
make progress is not by denying or
dismissing them but by tackling them and
solving them and
um so in my in my sort of main essay on
solutionism which I wrote for MIT
technology review I gave the example of
William Crooks who in 1898 were warned
the world that we were running out of
fertilizer
and that if we didn't solve the problem
uh we were heading towards famine and um
he was right the numbers you know we
were running out we were we were relying
on natural fertilizer and we were using
it up you know way faster than any any
processes were replenishing it and we
were going to run out you know it was
good that he foresaw that but he didn't
you know and so you could call him and
some people did call him alarmist
because he was warning of bad things
happening in some quite dire terms but
he didn't do this just to you know sell
books and get on talk shows which they
didn't even have talk shows back then
but you know he didn't and he did sell
books by the way he turned to speed he
made a speech uh to one of the
scientific uh societies and then he
turned it into a book which went through
like three editions so he did sell some
books but that wasn't his purpose his
purpose also by the way he did not call
for degrowth he didn't say we needed a
reduced population or you know anything
like that he said we need to invent
synthetic fertilizer and his main
purpose was to call on the chemists of
the world to uh come up with a way to
synthesize fertilizer and to fix
nitrogen and in fact he had the basic
idea correct he said we need to fix
nitrogen from the atmosphere uh and he
even had the beginnings of a plan of how
to do it now his plan was not the one
that ended up getting adopted he thought
we could do with electricity and we
ended up doing it with with uh chemistry
but uh you know it was he had an idea
and so he pointed the way and indeed
um within some 20 years or less chemists
did come to the rescue and created the
haberbatch process and and synthetic
fertilizer and so um so that is
solutionism right acknowledge the
reality of the problem fully embrace the
reality of the problem don't deny it or
dismiss it or put on your rose-colored
glasses and then go solve it and and
then we move forward and we solve the
problems of progress with more progress
It's it's the last part that might be
very difficult I mean we we have some of
the people who are working very close to
this in in the top AI companies and in
academic departments and non-profits and
so on uh talking about how difficult it
is to to solve the AI alignment problem
what is what does solutionism tell us
that we didn't already know in a sense
of course we have to solve the problem
you could say so what is what is it that
solutionism asks us to to focus on that
that's different well look solutionism
is a philosophy and philosophy only
takes you so far at a certain point you
pass over into technical details and
those have to be answered by the
engineers
um at the philosophical level I can't
tell you exactly which strategies are
most promising or where we should invest
resources right it's more of a way of
like looking at how to frame the problem
I mean I really think if you look at I
mean AI is just one example of this
um climate change is another example
there's lots of examples you get a lot
of people who are merely hard just
harping on the difficulties and then you
get people who don't want to hear the
pessimism who are then inclined to reply
by denying the existence of the problem
and I think once you're aware of that
pattern you can see it in a lot of the
discourse and you can avoid it in your
own thinking and in the way that you
talk about the problem and so I think
that's the value of having this concept
and and understanding this kind of uh
false dichotomy or this trichotomy you
know as for what to actually do again I
mean I'm not the expert there are people
there are a lot of different ideas I
think we should pursue all of them
um or anything that anybody thinks is
promising and and worth investing in I
mean I do think that we've been held
back for a long time by this will Echo
something I said a little bit a little
bit earlier but I'll I'll reinforce it
here and I'll cite part of where I got
this from was um Scott Aronson uh on the
he did a different podcast the um axrp
aixris research podcast it did a very
good interview with them where he
pointed out that like any field of
science or engineering to make progress
needs one of two things it needs either
empirical data uh or it needs uh like a
rigorous or like formal mathematical
Theory
and for decades AI safety has had
neither of those things and so it's been
very difficult to make progress now that
we have some pretty capable AI models we
finally have the ability at least to get
some empirical data and so actually now
might be the Golden Age of AI safety
like we can finally we can finally do
something about it because we can start
testing out hypotheses and so hopefully
that will make it easier to actually
make some progress one potential problem
there is that AI might be different than
others than other Technologies in that
it moves too quickly for us to do this
this uh trial and error and
experimentation that that has worked for
other Technologies such that whenever we
get these capable models that we have
now we are we are close to to even more
capable models and we don't have the the
years and years of of experimentation
that we might have had with say cars for
example or decades upon decades it might
be the case that we are now coming
around to thinking about technical AI
safety as a real problem and that we
have the funding and the means to
experiment and AI safety is becoming a
real field but is it perhaps too late
like first off historically speaking
I think we're extremely early when it
comes to thinking about AI safety like I
don't know many historical examples of
something where people have been so
concerned about safety for so long
before you had any like real capability
at all and where and where people were
researching it and writing papers and
creating entire institutes and and
everything like historically speaking
this feels to me like the most safety
conscious that Humanity has ever been
so
um like I don't know how it could have
been earlier
um and again there's there's only so
much progress you can make when you have
almost nothing to go on so again I don't
know I literally don't know if we had
just poured even more resources into it
even earlier I don't I I'm not convinced
that we wouldn't have just spun our
Wheels harder ultimately I think that
safety of this type especially from you
know safety that comes from research and
development and from you know things in
the lab
I think ultimately in large part it's in
the hands of the technologists
themselves who are on the front lines
they are the ones who are literally you
know or metaphorically standing in front
of Pandora's Box and holding the keys
right they're the ones who can decide to
open it or not and and whether to open
it in a secure contained facility or not
and Etc right and so I I think it's the
people who know the most about these
systems who understand them the deepest
and who are closest to the literal
concrete day-to-day decisions that are
being made who are best positioned to
make these decisions I'm not going to
tell them what they should be doing I
will tell them that I think they should
pay attention and take the issue
seriously just as if you were a bio
researcher in a lab I think you should
take the biosafety issues very seriously
right but I'm not going to tell the
biorecher with which pathogens are the
ones that require uh you know a negative
pressure laboratory and which ones
require full PPE and which ones require
I don't know what you know or all the
different mechanisms they use
I mean I do think we should sort of
think about it and take sensible
precautions
um certainly I mean certainly we should
think a lot about what are we hooking
these systems up to you know one thing I
would wonder about is sort of like
what's the security plan for GPT having
um uh you know an API access right to to
various things right it's getting tools
now and you can plug it into all sorts
of stuff and like you know what are
people going to do about that that seems
like a thing where okay now they can do
something other than just chat with me
you know that's that's certainly the
kind of thing where we want to think
very carefully about like what are we
hooking it up to just as we I mean as we
would think about you know if we're
going to give an API to anybody we would
think about what can this API do and
what might someone do with it right but
do you think AI is a normal problem so
do you think AI is a problem of the sort
that we have faced before and and solved
before or do you think AI risk might be
might be different I mean my first
question is are there any normal
problems like
I mean at what again at what level like
on some level it's a new different
problem there are many aspects of it
that are new and different
another level it's a problem in that
it's an aspect of reality that we have
to contend with and that's just like all
our previous problems right so it just
it just completely depends on what level
you're talking about do you think we can
handle AI risk with the sort of
traditional means here I'm thinking for
example of insurance so saying that
um AI companies by law must must be
insured to a certain extent so that's if
they cause damages they are liable for
those damages
I think that would certainly help if it
were defined properly right
um but again uh there's no Silver Bullet
right you need defense in depth so any
one of these when you're when you're
looking at a safety mechanism you don't
want to ask whether it will solve
everything because nothing will right
you just want to ask whether it's sort
of a good thing to layer on proper
definition of liability is essential and
having Insurance schemes for that
liability would help
um but nothing neither that or anything
else will solve the whole problem what
about the resources that we as a as an
economy are we're dedicating to research
into capabilities versus Research into
safety uh in in the in the field of AI
should we perhaps and and again here I'm
thinking about traditional means should
we perhaps be subsidizing Research into
safety because we believe that that too
much of resources to many resources
sources are going to AI capabilities I
mean it depends on who's we right and it
depends on what the what the proposals
are for what we would do with marginal
dollars like I don't I don't immediately
know within AI companies themselves I
mean I would like to see safety
integrated with the development uh I
mean it makes sense to have some of it
be separate certainly makes sense to
have kind of uh you know like a black
hat team right A Team who's not thinking
about it is not responsible for
capabilities
who then gets to think about what are
the ways this could go wrong and their
their whole job is to be the like the
the advocate for the other side of of
the um of the Judgment uh you know but
just in general uh are you know are are
there high Roi opportunities at the
margin that we're missing um like I
don't know off the top of my head here's
something concrete right per se a
wealthy philanthropist sponsors a a a
pool of prize money that's used to set
up a bug Bounty programs for for these
systems such that anyone finding a
security flaw can report that flaw and
uh get money from the from the price
money pool instead of perhaps using that
flaw in the system to earn money in some
illicit way oh yeah sure that's a good
idea I mean we do that for regular
software security as well right
companies have bug bounties and um that
sort of thing certainly helps
um you know much better to set up
incentives for people who discover flaws
to you know white hat report them rather
than exploit them so I've been talking
about Ai and and how it might be
different uh and and my thinking here is
that AI is sort of the ultimate general
purpose technology if electricity is
general purpose then intelligence is
definitely general purpose it's it's
kind of a meta technology that can
perhaps create other Technologies don't
you think that this this changes uh the
way we we see the trade-offs involved
that that we're dealing with something
here that that might be more powerful
than any technology we've faced before
certainly I mean we're very often facing
something that's more powerful than any
technology we've faced before because
that's the nature of progress and
Technology right you know when we
created nuclear power that was the most
powerful energy source we had ever found
and when we created internal combustion
engines they were the most powerful
engines we'd ever created in when we
created fire that was the most uh yeah
right we generally don't waste a lot of
time creating things that aren't going
to be more powerful than anything we've
ever created yeah no I think it's
certainly true
um and I mean look this is you know this
is part of the reason to be worried
about it it's also part of the the
reason to be excited about it uh I think
in general like any powerful new
technology is going to be maybe you know
sort of equal parts exciting and
worrying
um those things are going to go together
because the very nature of sort of power
of technology means it can be used for
great good and it can also be carelessly
or recklessly used or can be abused and
used for evil right that's just that's
the case with any new technology
what are you most worried about that we
will as a species as Humanity seriously
harm ourselves by by using but by AI
basically or that we will fail to
harness the the full power of AI fail to
use it to to use the technology to its
full potential
I'm not super worried about either of
those in the long run I think failing to
use it to its full potential is much
more plausible some sort of disaster
from AI is likely just because again I
mean every every new technology creates
the potential for disasters and often
creates disasters
um we have plane crashes we have nuclear
plant meltdowns we have you know all
sorts of things I expect some disaster
at that level from AI right but wouldn't
a disaster involving AI be more
analogous to a nuclear war than a plane
crash or a a a nuclear power plant
meltdown I mean it could be I mean you
could get things at any level right the
smaller disasters are more likely and
more plausible uh but obviously less
less impactful we started by talking
about economic growth and the history of
economic growth and now I think we
should we should talk about the the
future of of economic growth I I've um I
have this this uh this question that's
been kind of on my mind for a long time
which is just how long for how long can
current economic growth rates continue
into the foreseeable future and what
does foreseeable mean by the time we get
anywhere near the point where the growth
rates cannot continue
the unit the world and human life and
civilization will be so completely
unimaginably transformed that it'll be
unrecognizable from where we are today
so you know that point is Beyond the
Horizon of what we can foresee but there
are some physical limits and here I'm
talking about actual limits in physics
for example that we cannot expand beyond
Earth uh faster than the speed of light
sure sure there's only so much matter
and energy within our light cone right
and if you keep growing at even like
three percent a year or whatever you
know let alone if you project forward
the um the trend that I mentioned
towards the beginning where progress
actually speeds up over time
um then uh yeah then at some point maybe
you've used it all up I don't know it's
a little hard to say because again it's
just it's so far away from where we are
right now there's I just feel like
there's there's there's not one but
multiple barriers in between here and
there like where things are going to
transform so much that we just can say
almost nothing about what's beyond them
but you know all I know is that it'll
just be again it'll be a completely
unrecognizable world right it'll be a
world where there's no disease where
death is like completely optional where
we can travel anywhere in the universe
that is physically possible to travel
where we can build anything you know
that's physically built possible to
build as fast and as cheaply as
physically possible to build it where
we've already you know created
um all of the you know every possible
form of art personalized to every
possible different taste where we've can
transform our bodies and exp and inhabit
you know any kind of physical object
that is possible for our Consciousness
to inhabit where we've created every
sport and game that we can possibly
think of and have mastered them and had
every kind of competition where we've uh
you know where we've solved like
literally every problem in the universe
left to solve I just like I can barely
begin to guess at what that world looks
like and I don't think anybody else can
either and if we're just extrapolating
current growth rates out into the future
that world is perhaps thousands of years
away just because if if gross continues
but to that but two or three percent per
year for thousands of years we will
begin to hit these uh fundamental
physical limits but what about as you
mentioned what about if the growth rate
is itself speeding up here's here's one
scenario this is this is what I would
have called explosion uh economic kind
of growth explosion it just means that
the growth rates accelerate and we and
they reach kind of extreme levels this
Century so perhaps we see the the world
economy doubling every year or perhaps
even every month
and then the scenario that you just
described uh begins happening and much
uh much much at a much more in a much
more quick like much faster than we we
might have thought so perhaps this
Century as opposed to uh thousands of
years how plausible is this scenario and
is it if you just take if you just
extrapolate from the data we have today
um is it the conclusion you reach yeah
but it's very hard to you know put any
kind of numbers on it right but yes uh I
mean so I haven't done the math uh but
certainly if you if you project forward
the trends then you do get some you know
significant increase in the rate of
growth probably within the century and
maybe that means you hit some sort of
ultimate physical limits in centuries
rather than in Millennia or even sooner
I don't know again I haven't haven't
done all the math if you um I mean again
if you take the most naive curve fitting
and you you end up fitting like a
hyperbolic curve which goes infinite and
finite time and so like that can't
literally happen it's a failure of the
model when we get Infinities it's it's
not we're not actually projecting
infinite growth whatever that means you
know obviously there's some there's
something wrong with the model right but
maybe what's wrong with the model is
just that it doesn't account for hitting
physical limits or um or maybe there's
something else going on I don't know so
rather than a simple curve fitting
exercise which gets you maybe this sort
of hyperbola another way to do it is to
try to fit a series of exponential modes
so Robin Hansen attempted this in a
paper some decades ago and found that
with a little bit of
um sort of clever uh model selection and
parameter selection you can kind of fit
all of known or estimated uh economic
history going back millions of years to
um a series of three exponential modes
with a kind of smooth trade-offs or
smooth transitions between them and so
you know he roughly says okay maybe
these modes are like hunting farming
industry right and so the funny the the
fun thing about this is like if you look
at the trend if you look at the
relationship between one mode and the
next it turns out that each mode goes
like you know roughly two orders of
magnitude faster and
um and also the length of time
to the next mode arriving is like two
orders magnitude less
and if you extrapolate that out and say
well what if there's a fourth mode when
will it come and how fast will it go
then you get that like some fourth mode
would arrive sometime in this century
and um and it would just be it would
just be growing unimaginably fast
and the funny thing is and this is all
speculation of course and fun with
models but the funny thing is that it is
not that far off from
um you know the sort of scenarios that
Holden karnovsky has painted in in his
blog writing where he talks about
um you know AI automating all of human r
d essentially all of Science and
Technology and Industrial Development
and just getting some like insanely fast
growth rates so maybe we're on the cusp
of it then there's the extinction
scenario that perhaps if if you look at
it along the way it looks a bit like the
explosion of growth scenario as at least
as I as I imagine it perhaps AI helps us
have very fast economic growth until we
get again uh speculatively an AI
takeover and we go extinct and how do
you think of of that scenario nothing's
guaranteed I can't prove that it won't
happen like obviously we all hope that
it doesn't yeah okay then I have another
scenario that that I've called the
current normal goes on this is perhaps a
bit of a misleading title but that's
that's uh on purpose so this scenario
involves just uh we have this this two
to three percent growth rate uh into you
know the for the for this century and
perhaps we we have a better technology
in all sorts of ways but the world is
still recognizable to us now in in 2100
and we we still have problems we aren't
living in some sort of uh unrecognizably
great or unrecognizably bad World should
this be our default scenario or should
we perhaps think that we are living in a
special time of these growth rates
because historically the growth rates
we're seeing now are not uh are not
normal if we look at edit on on in the
grand scheme of things you know my first
prediction would be that the highest
level pattern will continue and the
highest level pattern is increasing
growth rates over time so I wouldn't
predict that 3 percent or we're getting
a little less than that growth you know
now
would continue in that ballpark forever
or you know for thousands of years I
would predict that the increase in the
growth rate would continue and that
things will speed up but again that is
not guaranteed either
um you know your normal you know normal
World continues scenario is maybe the
world uh uh where we get the butlerian
Jihad and uh we go to war against the
machines or at least the AI and destroy
all of it and uh and Outlaw it and then
you know just sort of continue on in our
20th century industrial mode you know
for forever if that's even possible I
mean I don't know okay I sort of doubt
it what about a scenario in which
civilization uh collapse but in a in a
slow way so perhaps we can imagine that
growth rates decrease and we slowly lose
knowledge we lose capabilities perhaps
population uh the populations decline
all over the world and then maybe we
maybe in some thousands of years we die
out in from a from a natural disaster
like like an asteroid or or a volcano or
or a pandemic or or something like this
yeah what do you think of that this
would be like if you took the great
stagnation and extrapolated that and and
took the the kind of most worrying
extrapolations of the the great
stagnation yeah I mean that's possible
civilizational collapse certainly has
happened before
um stagnation regression have happened
before I think we are I suspect we are
less vulnerable to civilizational
collapse than we used to be and I would
like to think that that Trend will
continue and that will continue to get
less vulnerable to collapse but I
haven't studied collapse in an up depth
to have a real Theory there all right
Jason it's been a real pleasure to have
you on thank you for coming on thanks a
lot it's been a fun conversation